La volta al món a peu, dia 256.
Doncs no era tan mal lloc al final, eh?
Igualment, m'he posat al despertador a les 5 i mitja,
he recollit ràpid, no m'ha vist ningú,
però crec que tampoc m'ha vist ningú, eh?
Perquè mireu, allà és on he campat,
a l'esquerra tinc aquesta fàbrica de... no sé, fàbrica d'algú.
I a dalt hi havia uns blocs,
i a l'altra banda del riu és on hi havia les cases,
que jo pensava que estaven al costat.
El terreny sí que tenia algú de privat.
O sigui, hi havia aquesta plataforma que els agraden els tejics de...
que dinen allà i algunes altres cosetes,
però estava bastant sol.
De fet, per la nit, baixa algú amb una llanterna i ni en veu.
És el color d'aquesta tenda verd fosc, que està molt bé perquè no et vegin, eh?
Els asses em van donar una mica de tabarra,
però bueno, en un moment els vaig dir
Ei, ei, fora!
I ja està, cap problema.
A veure, no ha sigut la nit que he tingut millor son reparador, la veritat no.
Però bueno, he dormit més del que esperava.
I ara estic al parc aquest tan mago, que és on ahir hi havia la festa.
Molt bé, estava trobant, buscant un endoi, però no l'he trobat.
Així que, bueno, seguiré fins que potser al següent poble hi hagi algun bar o restaurant o el que sigui.
Avui seria un dia per reconciliar-me, no?
Després de la mala tarda, que perdo el barret,
tot això que em va passar a l'hora de campar,
seria un dia per reconciliar-me, tant sigui que estic aquí,
i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí, i que estic aquí
banda de la carretera, tu. Cafès,
supermercats, tot.
Mireu, m'he comprat un barret.
3 euros
m'ha costat.
Bueno, té aquesta malla d'aquí.
Clar, això deixa passar el sol.
Jo, si fos calvo, doncs això no ho agafaria,
no? Però, no ho sé.
També deixa de transpirar més, no? Què en penseu?
Això, amb el sol aquí tot el dia, pot ser
perjudicial? Pel cuero
cabellut, en principi, tenint cabell no, no hauria de ser
cap problema, no? M'aprèn una mica.
Clar, no hi ha talla, saps? Vull dir, 3 euros
aquí és el que tenien. Jo tinc bastant
cabolo, vale? Jo necessitaria una talla gran.
Potser és d'una de sí?
Home, m'agrada que sigui bastant
això, no? L'altre
sempre feia com així,
es doblegava, tal. Aquest és com molt...
Molt, molt...
No sé com dir-ho ara en català.
Em surt en anglès. Bueno, és igual.
I és més ample, per tant, jo crec que em protegirà més del sol.
Però sí que m'aprèn
una mica. Bueno, pues res,
vaig a fer un cafè i a carregar la bateria, també.
Faltaria anar al supermercat, només.
Doncs ja està, tot fet.
Supermercat,
cafè, lavabo,
com sempre infecta,
i kebab!
Sí, kebab a les 7 del matí.
A la volta
al món a peu, un no menja
quan vol, sinó quan pot.
El que és raro és que
quan me l'ha donat m'ha dit, vol salsa?
Quan ja estava el kebab tancat.
I jo dic, sí,
ja em poso una salsa blanca per sobre.
Del kebab.
No ho he entès, això.
Vinga,
anem cap al túnel de la mort. Encara queda
uns 30 iats quilòmetres,
encara queda.
El barret queda una mica ridícul,
però bueno, em servirà com a mínim
fins a arribar a Dushanbe,
que per cert queda en uns 100 quilòmetres,
com heu vist, per tant arribem demà passat ja
a Dushanbe, la capital de Tajikistán.
Bueno,
m'estan fent una foto aquí.
Què és?
Anem a preguntar si és Dushanbe?
No.
Dushanbe o Dushanbe?
Dushanbe.
O Dushanbe.
No queda clar.
Molt bé.
Ok, ok.
Ok, bueno.
Fugam.
Aquí tenim la foto.
Bueno, no crec que és l'últim supermercat del dia,
o com a mínim abans d'entrar al túnel.
En aquest país mai saps si és l'últim o què.
I speak English.
I speak English, yes.
Oh, English.
English?
Sí, English.
Bueno, one second.
Llavors tinc una mica de fomo i m'he comprat aigua, un refresc, un gelat que se m'està derretint
i algú de picar per ara.
Només són les deu, però bueno, però no sé si tindrem més oportunitats.
He tret una mica el barret perquè m'està apretant bastant i ara bastant millor.
Bé, des d'aquí, des d'aquest pont que crec que és l'altre, que és l'altre, que és l'altre, que és l'altre, que és l'altre, que és l'altre.
Acabo de passar, comença la pujada a 1.000 metres de desnivell positiu en 17 quilòmetres, per una pujada relaxada,
fins a l'entrada del túnel de la mort, que no me l'he inventat jo el nom.
Es diu així.
La una, mitja pujada, al túnel queden 8 quilòmetres i 400 de desnivell positiu.
Home, no és una pujada molt forta, però el fet que sigui així, no sé.
I la calor, el sol, cansa.
Cansa més... el paisatge és brutal, eh?
És... és molt hostil el paisatge.
Aquestes muntanyes...
Súper altes, sota això són 3.000.
I tot tipus desert d'Arizona, saps?
Les típiques imatges que tenim de les pel·lícules.
Clar, però és un paisatge que va canviant molt a poc a poc, perquè les rectes dels cotxes són llargues.
Doncs mentalment cansa.
Vaig escoltant podcast, la ràdio, versió d'estiu...
Segueixo.
Aquest país no deixa de sorprendre'm.
Aquí, enmig del nord-est, a 6 quilòmetres del túnel,
hi havia un restaurant que no estava al mapa.
I diu, no, ja no tenim menjada, les safates.
Ens queda pollastre.
Chicken.
I jo, ah, vale, chicken.
El que no m'esperava és que em portessin un pollastre sencer.
I jo, hold, hold, chicken.
Bueno, crec que estaré una bona estona per acabar-me-la, eh?
Avui potser camino menys del previst.
Bueno, en realitat, anam bé molt de gust.
Bona nit.
Bona nit, a tots.
Les 4 de la tarda,
darrere meu, l'infame túnel de la mort.
Evidentment, no és el nou oficial.
El nou oficial és túnel d'Anzob.
que uneix tota aquesta part que hem estat caminant ara de Tajikistan
amb la capital i la resta del país.
Per tant, és un túnel superimportant.
L'alternativa abans de la seva construcció era pujar
per un port que està uns quants quilòmetres més enllà,
que arriba fins a més de 3.000 metres
i que, evidentment, dona molta corba,
és molt perillós i a determinades èpoques de l'any
és impossible de transitar.
Per tant, Tajikistan... No sé quan es va fundar aquest túnel.
Mira, ho posaré aquí.
Va afanyar-se a construir-lo
i quan va acabar l'excavació i la pavimentació ja el van obrir.
El van obrir abans de fer altres coses que s'han de fer en un túnel, no?
Llavors, què? Doncs no tenia bon drenatge
i estava ple de tois gegants d'aigua.
No tenia ventilació
i es juntaven gasos tòxics a dintre que flipes.
De fet, ara estic mirant
i no veig cap...
No veig cap mena de ventilador, eh?
Potser encara no té ventilació.
I tampoc tenia llum.
O sigui, era totalment a les fosques.
Ara veig alguna llumeta suelta.
Des de...
També hi havia alguns trossos de túnel per dintre.
Hi havia molts accidents, hi havia morts
i per això li van dir el túnel de la mort.
Des d'aleshores l'han millorat una mica pel que sembla
i ja no és tan dramàtic, evidentment,
però igualment creu aquest túnel
a peu.
Poques persones a la història ho deuen haver fet.
Poques.
No tinc gens de ganes.
Són 5 quilòmetres.
Per sort, és en lleugera baixada.
Per tant, en una hora ho hauríem de tenir llest.
I, bueno, pel que veig,
hi ha una espècie de plataforma,
com la majoria de túnels,
que està just al costat de la calçada.
Per tant, podré caminar per allà
sense haver de compartir el mateix espai amb cotxes.
Hi ha moltíssims camions que passen per aquest túnel,
perquè, bueno, aquesta és la carretera principal del país
i tots els camions ja van cap a la Xina o cap on sigui.
Intentaré sobreviure.
M'hauria anat bé una mascareta,
però mira, avui la farmàcia estava tancada.
Som-hi.
Procedeixo a entrar al túnel.
Estem a 2.870 metres sobre el nivell del mar.
No sé si dintre del túnel farà fred, farà calor.
Eh, bueno, calor no crec.
Evidentment, porto el frontal
i vaig per la banda esquerra, encara que no ho tinc clar, això, perquè
potser espanto els conductors amb la llum del frontal.
Ja es veu l'aire superdents, eh.
Mireu, l'aire...
És que ja estem a l'entrada, eh.
L'aire, no sé si es nota, però es veu superdents.
Els camions, clar, és que fan un soroll.
Ei, està mullat!
Està mullat el terra, això és una gran notícia.
Això vol dir que no aixecarà tanta pols.
Bueno, a veure fins on dura aquesta mullamenta.
Oh, ja estic tossint.
Vinga.
Hòstia, hòstia.
Hòstia, això és brutal, eh.
Acabo... Ja noto el gas, eh.
O sigui, l'olor a diesel i tal.
Mare meva.
L'espai aquest d'aquí
és
prou ample com per caminar ràpid, però
he d'anar molt atent
perquè
és fàcil com ensopegar-se entre cometes i
i baixar cap... i caure allà, eh.
Perquè l'espai aquí
és petit i toca... toca una mica...
No toca l'ombro, però
si no estic concentrat
pot tocar.
Per tal... Bueno, pausa.
Per tal que l'està concentrant.
Veig que el frontal no és del tot necessari.
La il·luminació és bastant decent, però bueno, igualment el mantinc.
Bueno, reporto
d'aquí una estona, una altra vegada.
No fa ni un minut que he acabat l'altre vídeo.
És bastant impracticable, eh, aquesta part.
Això és per quan vingui el camió
pujar-me i apartar-me i ja està, eh, perquè
caminar per aquí tota l'estona és bastant impossible.
Bé!
Moltes gràcies per la visita!
Gràcies, Ezequiel!
Home!
Moltes gràcies!
Gràcies!
Ostres!
Ai!
són les 5 i quart
porto gairebé una hora aquí
ara hem pitjorat bastant la cosa
ja estava malament
però és que com veieu
des de fa uns 10-15 minuts
ja no hi ha llum
i és bastant pitjor
perquè
amb el frontal
doncs m'hi puc veure
però
m'hi veig bastant menys
i
és bastant pitjor
bueno
això és horrible
és mega perillós
com veieu
ja no vaig per la plataforma aquesta lateral
perquè és massa estret
i no només per això
sinó perquè
aquí està sec
però hi ha molts trams
que hi ha fangs
i amb els fangs
et pots relliscar molt fàcilment
i una relliscada
podria ser fatal
llavors bé
com venen cotxes com ara
quedem els dos
i no passa res
quan ve un camió
llavors és una altra història
perquè
bueno
per si a cas
ui
ara aquí s'eixampla la cosa
quan ve un camió
doncs
llavors poso una cama aquí
o a vegades em puxo sencer
i el deixo passar més tranquil·lament
a més a vegades hi ha avançaments
aquest túnel és una locura
o sigui hi ha avançaments
i clar
quan l'avançament és darrere meu
doncs clar
doncs és molt perillós
perquè clar
no veig la persona que m'està avançant
bueno
no sé quan trigaré a sortir
perquè
com m'he d'anar apartant
m'he d'anar parant
doncs no sé
potser si no m'ho puc fer
serà més d'una hora
veig que ara
ui
veig la llum al final del túnel
la veig
sí
ha sigut
unes coses
bueno
després ho explico
però
potser
potser només la llum dels cotxes
potser no és que estigui
acabant el túnel
però veig que fa com una corba
i el túnel és bastant recte
vull dir que potser sí que està acabant
hi ha alguns trams que han anat corrent també
perquè
perquè bueno
així s'acaba més ràpid
però
he desistit de córrer
perquè
era massa cansat
sí sí
bueno
els rèpords no mentien
vull dir
el fet que no hi hagi il·luminació
no hi ha cap mena de ventilació
vull dir
és horrible
però bueno
jo pensava que el pitjor serien els fums
i el pitjor no són els fums
el pitjor és la periositat
de caminar
però d'anar en cotxe també
sí
sembla que s'acaba
ai que no ho he dit
aquesta espècie de coneta aquí
que ara corre aigua
a un tram
la majoria de tram
era fang
i clar
no ho he vist
i ha fotut el peu
i m'ha quedat el peu així
i ara el tinc així encara
sí
ja tenim la sortida
de veritat
ha sigut l'estona
més angoixant
de tota la volta
de moure el peu
no m'esperava
que fos tan horrible
mare de Déu Senyor
ho he aconseguit
he creuat el túnel de la mort
locura tio
locura
ai ai ai
ai ai que em mato
la gent està flipant aquí al darrere
suposo que he de tenir parts de la cara bastant negres
no ho sé
però els braços
mireu com els tinc
mare de Déu Senyor
ho he aconseguit
mireu com els tinc
mare de Déu Senyor
ho he aconseguit
mireu com els tinc
mare de Déu Senyor
horrible
ostres tu
sort que ho sabia eh
jo sabia que hi havia aquest túnel aquí
perquè havia vist
d'altres aventurers
d'un aventurer Alexander Campbell
que l'havia creuat
no havia fet tant drama a ell
ostres
uf
us he de dir que hi ha moments que m'he espantat
fins i tot tenint en compte
que tinc seguros d'escribar
Segur, senyor Escribà, és la meva assegurança que em protegeix absolutament de tot, a tot el món.
A Tajikistán i a la Xina popular.
Tot arreu.
Per qualsevol cosa que em passi.
Fins i tot que m'atropin al túnel de la mort.
Però encara així, estava espantat, home, és que, mare meva.
Senyor Escribà, a la seva web ho posa.
Assegurances per viatges d'aventura.
Què hi ha més aventurer que creuar el túnel de la mort?
No cal, però no cal arriscar tant.
Bueno, no cal, no cal.
Sí, no, és veritat, no cal.
Segur, senyor Escribà, per viatges en càmper també us serveix.
Vull dir, si heu de creuar aquest túnel en càmper, tampoc les tindria totes amb mi, saps?
Per viatges en bicicleta, als Himalayas, al Camí de Sant Jaume, a la Sierra 11, el que sigui.
Amb aquest codi d'aquí teniu aquest tant per cent de descomptat.
No me'n recordo mai.
Però bueno, el teniu aquí en pantalla per contractar qualsevol assegurança amb Segur, senyor Escribà.
El podeu contactar.
A la seva web o també per Instagram.
Tenen Instagram, asseguratuaventura.
Doncs allà els teniu.
Gràcies, Segur Escribà, per tenir-me relativament tranquil, encara que em busqui problemes.
Bueno, i ara què?
Doncs més túnels.
Més túnels, però com podeu veure, aquests túnels es poden vorejar per allà, per fora.
No cal entrar a dintre.
I bé, hem de baixar per tota la carretera.
Ara és baixada, baixada, baixada.
I veieu allà que arriba fins al final i després hi ha un petit camí que remunta al riu?
Doncs per allà hi ha una suposada, bueno, àrea més o menys plana de campada,
i de fet ja l'estic veient des d'aquí, on en teoria camparem per allà.
Teoria, eh?
Però sí.
Aquesta és la propera parada.
Així tu ho ve quin diòleg.
No passa res, però.
Tot el que hem vist ara a l'etat key té un punt de partida molt dinàmica.
No hi ha més homepage ni de cap cosa.
I de fet, la research d'aquest túnel s'ha produït per la
metàfora de l'ideal de les dades, que és l'idea que pot fer-se una
fórmula de la vida i la part d'interessos.
I de fet, l'idea que es pot fer amb aquests túnels, que són els minis,
de la qualitat de l'economia i el carrer.
De fet, la investigació ja es fa a casa les fot en casa!
Deixo ja la carretera
aquí estan els camions
i agafo aquesta pista
que hem vist des de dalt
allà dalt estava
bueno, veig bastanta activitat, veig un cotxe allà
veig aquí unes cabanes amb unes tendes de campanya grans
gent jugant
he vist abans un ciclista bastant més allà
i aquí uns moters
que, bueno, estan duixant bé tan a prop
duixant més de
menys d'una hora, jo crec, amb moto
doncs dubto que es quedin aquí a campar
normalment els moters tampoc
són molt de campar
bueno, tinc opcions
també m'agradaria estar a prop del riu
per passar-me una aigua, encara que aquesta aigua
estarà freda perquè ve directament
des de les glaceres d'aquestes muntanyes d'aquí
doncs els motoristes resulta que sí que campen aquí
són una bona colla
i són força simpàtics
i de Lituània
sí
després m'han dit si vull anar amb ells
porten cadires
jo no
però sí, sí, ara després aniré amb ells a menjar jo pa amb formatge inmund
ells tindran suposo que un tiberi més interessant
doncs els motoristes resultava que sí que han acampat
i han resultat ser molt simpàtics
i de Lituània, no?
Lituània
sí, sí
hola
com estàs?
hola amigos
hola noches
aquest senyor és instagramer també
pots dir-ho a la teva pagina d'Instagram?
sí, som a l'Instagram
és Adventuriste
motocicletes, expedicions i aventures
doncs pots mirar-les
i m'expliquen una mica la seva viatge
però pots repetir-ho de nou per a l'audiència?
sí, doncs estem viatjant a través de tres països
doncs és Kyrgyzstan, Uzbekistan i Lituània
doncs estarem aquí per gairebé tres setmanes
i farem almenys 3.500 km durant aquesta viatjada
doncs estarem portant motocicletes BMW
i estem mixant la campanya amb els hotels
i hem conegut un personatge increïble
que va viatjar arreu del món
de seguida, tu saps?
encara no entenc com és possible
però sí
tu m'has dit que moltes coses s'han passat a tu
al grup
pots explicar una d'aquestes coses?
ja hem passat dues fronteres
algú ja ha perdut el passaport
per un temps tan curt
però ara va tornar
doncs avui va ser una estrada fantàstica
una estrada bastant difícil
i interessant
amb els túnels llargs i els darrers
sense les llars
la pol·lucionació l'aeroport No ho sé
Tres centenars
Tres centenars sí
Tu tens com set o deu minuts
sí
però enfonsàvem amb les motocicletes
i vam pensar
Oh, som heroes
i ho vam fer
i ara vau arribar
i vau dir
que ja hagués caminat al túnel
tu fas el Pammir, oi?
sí
de Pamir Highway.
Ok, quin és el punt de vista de la teva viatge?
El que estàs buscant el més?
El lloc que vols visitar el més?
No és un lloc, però bàsicament
només la rota i les muntanyes.
El nostre punt més alt serà
d'aquí a 4.650 metres,
crec.
Aleshores, estem
preguntant com ens sentirem
en aquest lloc
i
quines veus podem
esperar allà.
Ok, tu només has de
campar el més alt possible el dia abans
i seràs una mica aclimatitzat, crec.
Sí, sí, definitivament
hem de fer això.
Ok, bé, bona sort amb la teva viatge
i anem a menjar.
Bé, tu avui, 46 quilòmetres, estic
baldat, mil i escaig, 1.300
de desnivell positiu.
He parlat amb
cinc persones, comptant dos
motoristes i tres d'un banc
que me senten tallats que m'han fet les fotos.
M'he pres dos refrescs
només
i m'he gastat 19 euros.
El pollastre i el barret
han fet pujar la mitja avui.
Bueno, el túnel de la mort
ha sigut una
experiència horrible.
Una
de les coses, de les pitjors coses
que he fet mai i de les més perilloses
que he fet mai.
No us ho recomano, evidentment.
Home, ara em sento satisfet de dir, ei,
he creuat a peu el túnel de la mort.
Però és una cosa absurda, realment.
És una cosa...
És molt absurd.
Ells s'han quedat flipant quan els he explicat que
he creuat el túnel de la mort a peu.
En fi, demà...
Demà, demà, eh?
Demà baixada fins a Duxembe.
Clar, són molts quilòmetres, eh? Fins al centre
són, tipus, 60. O 60
i pico. És massa. Sí que és veritat que és tot
baixada, eh? Però jo què sé,
no sé, potser em quedo a les afores...
M'he rentat aquí els peus
ara. I a les cames, sobretot, que era el que
tenia més guarro, les cames.
Tot ple de fang. Però m'he
necessitat una dutxa, sobretot del cap.
El noto que està ple de carbó...
Sutge... De tot.
Bueno, ja ho veurem demà.
Bona nit.